c'est une volte face surprenante de la
part des autorités américaines
l'importation de saumon génétiquement
modifiés sera interdite aux etats-unis
en tout cas temporairement la décision
survient à peine deux mois après qu'on
ait approuvé ce même ce moment pour la
consommation humaine
bonsoir 4e dont céline le saumon
génétiquement modifiés c'est un aliment
qui fait pas du tout l'unanimité alors
commençons par expliquer ce que c'est
ouais selon ses détracteurs il l'appelle
franck une fiche rousseau monstres ça
donne déjà le ton les rassurera
exactement ça aurait été le tout premier
animal génétiquement modifiés destinés à
la consommation humaine
ce sont des chercheurs canadiens en fait
qu'ils ont inventé mais la société qu'il
développe
aquabounty c'est une société américaine
elle affirme qu'il grossit deux fois
plus vite qu'un saumon de l'atlantique
traditionnel donc vraiment au niveau des
coûts de production le ça représente des
économies
ce saumon là il a été conçu avec des
jeunes issus de deux autres sortes de
poissons
le saumon chine nous quitte un saumon du
pacifique et la loket d'amérique qui
ressemble un petit peu à une anguille et
aquabounty afyon qu'il ne produit que
des femelles stériles qui techniquement
ne peuvent pas se reproduire
mais la stérilisation - ce n'est pas sûr
à 100% la compagnie l'admet elle même et
donc la crainte qu évidemment en cas
d'accident ou de négligence des saumons
arrive à s'échapper dans l'environnement
et à se reproduire avec des espèces
sauvages
mais pourquoi est ce que les états unis
ont finalement décidé de dire non à ce
moment là c'est peut-être la pression
populaire la pression politique 1 il
semble qu'on veuille finalement se
donner un petit peu plus de temps avant
d'ouvrir cette porte là même si ça fait
plus de vingt ans que la compagnie
aquabounty réclament le droit de
commercialiser son produit aux états
unis cette volte-face de la food and
drug adminstration la f10 elle s'est en
partie la victoire d'une sénatrice de
l'alaska qui a milité très très fort
pour interdire la vente de poissons
transgéniques aux états unis faut savoir
que en alaska il ya une industrie du
2 du saumon pardon qui est florissante
et ça aurait pu nuire à l'image de cette
industrie là et aussi il n'y avait aucun
étiquetage dans les directives annoncé
au mois de novembre donc impossible pour
les consommateurs de savoir s'il a
acheté du poisson transgénique ou non
donc là la f10 en surprenant
positivement la f10 dit c'est pas
d'importation tant qu'on n'a pas trouvé
une façon d'étiqueter ce produit là et
certains experts disent que ça pourrait
prendre plusieurs années et au canada
donc puisque ce produit a été inventé
ici mais on peut pas le consommer chez
nous n'ont pas de consommation l'examen
de salubrité est toujours en cours
auprès de santé canada mais la
production elle est permise les yeux
sont produits déjà dans une ferme
piscicole de l'île du prince édouard et
ce qui est intéressant c'est l'insee que
le processus est beaucoup plus opaque
ici qu'aux états unis a pas eu de
consultations publiques aux états unis
après deux millions de personnes qui se
sont opposés à l'arrivée de ce poisson
là dans les supermarchés ici on n'a pas
demandé l'avis à la population alors que
quand même 80 % des canadiens qui ne
sont pas d'accord qui veulent
l'étiquetage au moins des ogm donc
justement
bon bah c'est intéressant est un peu
inquiétant quand même merci beaucoup
pour trouver un prix